>>Alicia: I need my game master
to please retrieve a bin of blocks
and I need my supply master
to retrieve your supplies.
>>Constantly challenging kids in
the classroom affects learning,
depending on the challenge.
And I think at Quest, which is
something that really drew me
to Quest, and what we do really well,
is that in each class we
challenge them in different ways.
So they don't always know what to
expect, which is totally different
than the traditional classroom,
which I've never seen any
other school do, or do well.
>>My worthless turn.
[ laughs ]
>>You could borrow mine.
>>No, we're done,
we're done, we're done.
>>Angus, roll one more time.
>>Get a six, get a six!
>>Six.
>>No, I think
I'm winning because I--
>>Six is the bomb,Yaaww!
>>Alicia: Caterpillar
is a board game.
It uses dice and it uses colored
blocks and you can play it
with either two, three
or four people.
The goal is to create
the longest caterpillar,
but when you record the
dice rolls, you are looking
for something called the bomb.
So the bomb is the most frequently
rolled number and as you play,
you figure out that the most
frequently rolled numbers are towards
the middle, so your five,
six, seven and eight.
And you try to build as
much around it as possible,
so you can get more blocks, but
in the end, if that number blows,
all of your caterpillar
pieces go with it.
So it's using skill but
it's also using chance.
>>Student: It depends who the
players are you're playing
with because some are really good
and some like, you know, are like me,
are like beginners, because I
usually don't win every round
of Caterpillar that I play.
I usually win like out of
five, only once or twice.
But yeah, it depends on the person.
It doesn't depend on the
game, but on the person.
>>Alicia: When you have problems that
are just out of your reach in school
or in life, you learn how to roll
with the punches and figure out,
"Okay, I have this skill
set and I just learned this
from this past challenge, and now
this past challenge is solved,
but I have this other
challenge over here."
And if it's constantly changing
and you have these skill sets
that are also adapting and changing
with you, giving them things
that are just out of
their reach requires them
to build that like mental muscle.
It strengthens something, whether
it's your mind or physically,
and if we gave them challenges
that just met where they are,
their toolbox, their mental
toolbox would never grow.
>>Student: It's also fun
building out your caterpillar
and seeing how much land you
can like preserve for yourself.
Like I always enjoy conquering
the most land and feeling
that I've really accomplished
something.
>>Alicia: I can't speak for any
other discipline but I know in math,
it's allowed me to see really quickly
and easily where my students are
and what their weaknesses are
and what their strengths are
and what they're being asked to
do and, a lot of times you fail
at giving them the
right challenge problem.
And it's through that failure
that you learn how to adjust
and you learn what
you're looking for.
>>Student: Without challenge,
it would just be like,
in a game for example, it would just
be like, it doesn't really matter
who wins and it won't be as fun.
>>Student: Caterpillar is fun to
play because the game is challenging
and you want to have the
longest caterpillar at the end
of the game, after the bomb explodes.
>>Student: It's always about what
one number will be rolled the most
and which one will be the bomb
and getting away from that area
and getting to an area that will also
be rolled a lot, but not as much.
>>Alicia: The toughest part of
teaching and of doing anything
where you want anybody to learn, it's
about knowing where your students are
and knowing what their
limits are at the moment,
and stretching that limitation.
Because I don't care what end
of the spectrum you're on.
I don't care if you know
everything in middle school math,
I can find something
to challenge you.
And I promise you I will,
and it will be tough.